aimé césaire c'était un poète et un
homme politique martiniquais mais il ya
100 tonnes
samedi une journée de manifestations
culturelles été organisée pour lui
rendre hommage à la médiathèque comme de
la verrière comme ces antillais fier de
partager leur culture
martiniquaise pour tanner gros
martiniquaise parce que c'est une
identité
ce sont c'est un métissage le bel ace
est un métissage entre la culture
européenne et la culture africaine
pourquoi le negro parce que justement
elle était partie aux antiques de noir
explique qu'ils représentent et
martinique est parce que c'est de la
martinique
chants et danses à compagnie de flûte
hong kong ou de petits bois d'un monica
et de tambours les représentations
matinales ont ravi le public qui a
accepté l'invitation sur la canicule
cette danse de réjouissance un
commandement très festive
une journée qui s'est poursuivie autour
de lectures de contes tables rondes ou
encore de théâtre toujours dans la
médiathèque symbolique
aimé césaire aimé césaire au travers de
l'oeuvre d'un individu marque aussi la
volonté d'une expression personnelle
d'une reconnaissance aussi d'un individu
d'un peuple d'une histoire
le message global qui l'a fait passer
qui est pour moi
au delà de l'individu au delà de la
culture j'ai quelque chose à dire
j'existe et je le fais encore l'hommage
a ainsi clôturé la 6e biennale de la
poésie au dire des poètes